so I'm Susan Elias the biology writer at
science news and I'd had a very bizarre
and entertaining year writing about
mosquitoes of all things mosquito is
suddenly mattered you could have
conversations with people at dinner
parties about mosquitoes some of the
most interesting conversations I had
were with researchers who talked about
what we don't know about mosquitoes
which mosquitoes actually carry Zika the
World Health Organization in the CDC had
long been saying that it's ATS a chip
time mosquito and another babies
relative but it's been taught in Brazil
but maybe there's a very different genus
of mosquito the southern hangs mosquito
which is a cool accent skeeto that might
actually be spreading it and always been
paying much attention to them the
results have been mixed this would turn
everything upside down we might have to
rethink a lot of how it might spread
where it might spread weather and we
spread whether a mosquito can spread a
disease is very different from whether
it actually will because mosquitoes have
tastes like everybody else this big
question about what the Culex mosquitoes
actually like to bite me who's this sort
of creep of the chocolate of mosquito
and his broccoli with respect
of course so I think 2017 is going to be
an exciting time as people sort of how
they feel about using genetically
modified insects for mosquito control
Keywest has become just a storm center
for debate about this the mosquito
control people in Key West have decided
that they are going to have a test
genetically modified mosquitoes this
would be the first genetically modified
mosquitoes to flap through us bear
what's ahead for 2017 is that they are
going to relocate the test and find
another area within the same County
where people aren't as upset by it and
then this requires going guys your
governor regulations again there's been
a great deal of fuss about this as an
experiment in the US but it's not so
experimental anymore inside the u.s.
Brazil has had free flying genetically
modified mosquitoes for several years
now and they've been released in other
countries too this is not the first and
free-flying
genetically modified insect to be
released in the u.s. that was the paint
bomber in the southwest so there's to be
something about a mosquito but just yes
people
on set we talk about the mosquito when
it's actually lots of mosquitoes and
there are 3,500 species in the world
some of them don't like what some of
them are reportedly pretty some of them
actually are important to to ecosystems
like a carnivorous plant which of the
pitcher plants have their own sort of
pet mosquitoes it's sad that we don't
recognize that the great diversity of
mosquitoes out there you think that I'm
either an animal and everybody
recognizes I don't think anybody has
them on their curtains and pajamas when
their kids are head stuffed mosquitoes
[Music]